لعلها هي من المعارض المميزه التي تقام او
تحديدا تقام في مقر اليونسكو في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس وتحديدا اليوم نتحدث عن
معرض استثنائي او مختلف وهو يتحدث عن
الراحل الملك فيصل خاصه بعد مرور مئه عام
من رحلته التي
ذهب اليها في باريس اليوم هذا المعرض
يتحدث ليس فقط عن شخصيه الفيصل لا يتحدث
ايضا عن القيادات التي التقاء انما ايضا
يعرض ما كان يقتنيه الملك فيصل انذاك عند
زيارته الى باريس عموما كل هذه التفاصيل
سوف نتحدث بها مع
المتحدثه في اول الاستاذه رشا الفواز وهي
مديره اداره المتاحف والاصول في مركز
الملك فيصل للدراسات والبحوث الاسلاميه
مرحبا بك استاذ رشا ونتحدث اليوم سريعا عن
هذا المعرض كيف يتحدث اليه الغرب اليوم
سعداء فان معرض الفيصل رحله في القرن
العشرين يحط رحاله في محطه الثانيه في
باريس بعد محطه لندن والجميل انه في مقر
اليونسكو وهو يعني نعتقد انه هو مناسب
لهذه الشخصيه ولهذا
مكانته ووضع السياسي في هذا المكان
زي ما تشوف احنا عرضنا في هذا المعرض رحله
الملك فيصل اللي هي بداها من نجد من
الرياض في عام 1919 ميلادي وانتقل فيها
بالسفينه الى البحرين ومن البحرين الى
عمان ومن عمان الى الهند ومن الهند الى
لندن بريطانيا ايرلندا وينتهي في باريس
ونركز في الاخير على الارث اللي تركه
الراحل الله يرحمه طيب اليوم نشاهد بعض
يعني المقتنيات التي يقتنيها الملك فيصل
مثل هذه هذا السيف وكذلك ايضا بعض
المقتنيات هنا في بعض الاواني التي تعرض
في هذا المعرض الاول مره بالنسبه للسيف
اللي ترى امامك هو السيف مهم جدا في تاريخ
السعودي لانه يتكلم هذا سيفت طوسون باشا
من الدرعيه في وقت الفتره الدوله السعوديه
الاولى وموجوده من مقتنيات الملك فيصل
وحرسنا ان نعرضها في هذا القسم من المعرض
ايضا هذه جانب كما ترى بعض من اواني
الملك فيصل الله يرحمك كان يحب البر وكان
دائما وحتى وهو ملك انه تغيب الشمس في
البر فهذه الادوات اللي تستخدمها في رحله
البريه
طيب اليوم راح نشاهد اول مره مره برضه
وتعرضون الزي اللي كانوا يقتنيه الملك
فيصل في رحلته لباريس ولعلها تعرض لاول
مره على شاشه العربيه زي الكامل زي الملك
فيصل صحيح صحيح هنا الملك فيصل الله يرحمه
في رحله الى لندن عمره 13 سنه
بالسفينه بملابس
واشارت له الصحافه الغربيه بهذا اللبس
الغريب او الزائر الغريب
حافظ على شكله على هويته ما تخلى عن اي
شيء من تقاليدك ايضا اذا تشوف سبق ومرت
الكاميرا على حتى المرافقين معاه في
الرحله كلهم كانوا الضيوف النجديين اللي
انتقلوا من نجد رياض 1919 الى الى الهند
بهذا اللبس هذا اول وصول لهم للهند بهذا
الزي اليوم يعني
رجع
كاستخدامه في الوقت الحالي في لدى الشباب
والشابات السعوديه
ولعل هذا يكون نموذج واضح للشباب كيف كان
الشكل التقليدي للملابس الشعبيه او
للديجلا
والمقصب وايضا لدينا بعض الصور وصور
لزياره العده الدول بعد يعني وصوله او
تغطيه عمر العشرين يعني هنا برضه في لدينا
في الهند وبعض ايضا الدول في دول اوروبا
تحديدا صحيح ولكن خلى الفت نظرك الى صورته
هذا اول بورتريه شخصي رسم للملك فيصل وهذه
النسخه الاصليه رسم في السفينه وهو رايح
لهذه الرحله وعمره 13 سنه باريس رحله الى
رحله باريس او رحله تقريبا هي رحله
البريطانيا بدعوه من الملك جورج الخامس
وفي هذه الرحله رسمت الرسامه الملك فيصل
هذا اول بورتريلا وهذا اول شكل له يطلع
قدام الكاميرا اول مره يواجه الكاميرا في
حياته نروح للجناح الاخيره والقسم الاخير
طبعا المعرض فاطمه هو كبير جدا يحتوي على
مقتنيات كثيره وكذلك صور عديده ولكن نحن
نتجول وناخذ الابرز
لحياه الفيصل نتحدث ايضا عن السيف المراه
الاخرى ولكن بشكل اخر
لك
فيصل نقع دعوه من الملك جورج الخامس الى
بريطانيا
مع خطاب من والد الملك عبد العزيز كان
وقتها حاكم نجد واخذ معاه هديه وهذا السيف
واهداء الى الملك جورج الخامس عنده مقابله
تالا